okay uh we were just listening to an
interview I did with a bunch of the
Avengers cast and we were talking about
what kind of meats we would be and I've
been joined in studio I don't know how I
feel about this by my longtime companion
Jordan schlansky hi
uh wow brimming with enthusiasm Jordan
that was interesting conversation I
thought okay I'll go along with that
premise what kind of meat do you think
you would be what kind of the Avengers
were just talking about what kind of
meats they would be what kind of meat
would you be oh I'd probably be uh
Tuscan cannina Bullock an uncastrated
Bullock the famous white cow known
throughout Tuscany also Umbria and Lazio
but specifically Tuscany which provides
the meat for the famous bistec a la
Fiorentina which should always be cooked
all sangwe with only salt preferably
over a wood fire
incredible
um I don't know
why I thought I'd hear anything less
than a nine minute monologue why does
the bull need to be castrated I didn't
say the bull needed to be castrated I
said in certain countries a bullock is
known to be castrated in other countries
for example in North America the Bullock
is not castrated however in the United
Kingdom the Bullock is castrated how
does that affect the taste of the meat
uh well in fact the bean castrated does
affect the taste of the meat and in
Italy they'll call a castrated lamb like
a castrato it has its own name because
people seek that Meats flavor there's
hormonal changes I'm not familiar with
the endocrine system of Urus I've never
I've never heard you say for a second
that you were unfamiliar with something
I mean if you were castrated do you feel
it would change if I were castrated I
was castrated in 1991. what are you
talking about okay there are changes
that happen oh I'm quite aware yeah a
lot of uh what we know of ourselves is
based on our testes what do you mean
is based on a person we know as
ourselves is a combination of many
complex factors not the least of which
are our testes which provide certain
hormones and other physical reactions
that occur to produce the person that
you know today okay so you say you are
your is basically what you're
saying
when we talk about castration that may
be involved but we're really talking
about the testes I think I said testes
testes
testes okay
most people when they're working with a
microphone as you are now say testing
testing testing but you just said testes
testes testes that was kind of a
humorous clip on my part and you would
probably be a pork chop uh
why do you say that was such disdain
what's wrong with a pork should it be a
pork chop uh with the fat cap that has
not been properly scored to the point
that once it hits that Hot Grill it
curls up immediately you are curled up
in the fetal position with your fat cap
you are a pork chop Jesus
indictment you say that it's such a
lowly thing I think what's wrong with
I'm not making any judgment on the way
he's describing hey if you're listening
right now and you heard disdain in
Jordan's voice honk your horn wow that's
going to be a lot of horns honking
across this great old USA I like pork
chops I have no problems with pork chops
what's the problem with being a pork I
love do you disagree I love nothing more
when I'm walking down the street and I
see a sign that says we've got Steaks
and Chops I'm there I love a good old
Chop House and if I'm in Baltimore it's
a Baltimore Chop House I salute it three
times before I go in and stuff my face
so don't put down a pork chop I think
it's a great part of America what I'm
saying is you do a lot of Jordan is you
talk about well in Umbria they do this
and in bullion and they do that and then
you look at me and you go you and your
pork chop well guess what there's a
bunch of Americans here who love a pork
chop I like a hot dog or like a pork
chop I like a hamburger because I love
the United States of America Jordan and
you should try to love it too or buddy
you better leave it you're a pork chop
now when you have a pork chop there's a
fat cap okay now if you don't score the
fat cap the pork chop curls in some
feeble flailing display when it hits
that Hot Grill you're not me you don't
mean to be derogatory in any way I'm
curled in a feeble way talking about a
pork chop you just said I am that pork
chop I didn't say you're that pork chop
I said you're a pork chop yes it's
possible you've not been properly scored
and you curl in in some kind of flailing
motion uh which I'll call fetal okay
Jordan if we did a remote where you were
castrated would you agree to go along
with that no I would not okay what if we
surprise you
no that doesn't if I call you to walk
into the office and you come in and
there's a little table and you put your
feet in some straps and they've got the
old that's probably how it happened we
got the old chaparoonie there going you
know yeah anywho that's the problem
you'd probably taste different later on
do you think you would taste differently
if we castrated you how long before we
noticed the difference in taste when we
cooked your flesh I do think I would
taste different if you were to eat my
flesh uh I guess we're having this
conversation thank you for choosing the
premise so uh intelligently yes if we
were to remove my testes I might have a
different flavor we're one to then eat
my flesh that's two perverse behaviors
that would need to be performed to yield
this result okay well you suggested it
we're gonna make it happen stay tuned to
Team Coco radio Sirius channel 106.
Jordan will be castrated and then at
some point later on once his body has
undergone certain changes he'll be
cooked and eaten that's the kind of
stuff you can look forward to on this
channel
you're not going to find that on Yacht
Rock baby